ş hayatın adının düğüm olduğunu
öğrendiğimde çok şaşırdım Çünkü
geçtiğimiz dönem yaptığım bir fotoğraf
projesinin adı da düğümü ve bu hocanın
bana verdiği e konu seçimleri arasında
yoktu İstediğiniz bir konuyla
gelebilirsiniz demişti Ve ben dmü seçtim
sonra alt başlıklarının kendini bil
Kendine Ada ve ve Kazan olduğunu
öğrendim bu daha da ilginçti Çünkü ben
fotoğraf projemin düğüm etrafında
yaparken hep şey
düşünmüştüm Biz kendi kendimize ya da
çevremiz tarafından atılan düğümlerle
yönlendiriliyor Herkesin bir yolu var ve
bu
yol düğümlerle Karman çorman olmuş halde
ve o düğüme her takıldığında geri
dönüyorsun fotoğraf rejime geçmeden önce
biraz daha bu yolda nasıl ilerlediğim
konuşmak istiyorum aslında biz kendi
kendimizi sabote ediyoruz kendimizi
gerçekleştirme yoluna attığımız düğümler
bizim ilerlememiz engel oluyor kazanmak
içinse yani son Başlığa ulaşmak için
kendini bilmek kendini tanımak adamak
gerekiyor ve bu ancak düğümlerin
çözülmesinden geçiyor diye
düşünüyorum ben psikoloji okuyorum
psikoloji öğrencisiyim bu sene mezun
olacağım
psikolojiden her bölümün kendine
bazı önyargıları vardır mesela
mühendislerin romantik partnerler
bulamayacağı gibi Hukukçular çok
konuştuğu gibi işciler yıı gi
uğ çevremden gelen tepki şu oluyor deli
Doktorum olacaksın bizi de tedavi
edersin artık ve ondan sonra karşıdaki
seni biraz daha kendine yakın görmeye
başladığımda nasıl mutlu olabilirim
çocuğum Beni hiç dinlemiyor Bilmem kimde
dikkat eksikliği var Bence bunun
tanısını nasıl koyabiliriz falan devam
ediyor ve ben bu konuşmaların sonunda
her seferinde psikoloji okumaya Aslında
insanı tanımak için başladığımı
söylüyorum Çünkü insan muazzam bir şey
muazzam bir dünya Ben her zaman
etan göz insanlar birler nerelı g
ama
GM
kar karşımızdaki insanlarda yansımamız
görmemize neden olduğunu fark ettim
tanıştığım Her kişide kendimin bir
yansıması vardı ve kendimi bulmak için
önce karşımdakiler anlamam gerektiğini
düşünüyordum sonra bu insanı tanıma
anlama süreci ilerledikçe Tamam ben
insanı tanıyorum anlıyorum ama insan
anlatmak istiyorum dönüştü işte küçük
öyküler yazmaya başladım fotoğraflar
çekmeye başladım işte medy görsel
sanatlar insan anlatma sürecinde bana
yardımcı olabileceğini düşünmeye
başladım medyanın anlattığım şeyi
paylaşmakta yardımcı olabileceğini
düşünmeye başladım ve medya ve görsel
sanatlara çift anda
başladım Bu sefer başka önyargılar çıktı
karşıma marjinal misin sanatçımı
olacaksın mezun olunca ne yapacaksın
hiçbirini bilmiyorum gerçekten sadece
tek bildiğim insanı merak ettiğim
anlamak istediğim ve Anladığım kadarıyla
el yordamıyla bozduğum her şeyi bir
şekilde karşımdakiler anlatma aktarma
isteğim oldu
İnsanların iç Dünyalar Savaşı gördüm
kendim yansım kendi yansımamı
gördüğümden bahsetmiştim Az önce
tanıştığım Her kişi benim hiçb fikrim
olmayan ya da size hiç çaktır olabilir
karşıdaki Herkes kendi iç dünyas bir
büyük savaş yaşıyor ve bu savaşı
gördükçe insanlara karşı bir daha nazik
davranmaya başladım ama başka bir konu
hoşgörünün başlamasıyla ilili bir yere
gilir
projeme geçmek istiyorum artık kendi
yansımamı karşım görmekten sıkıldım ve
kendi büyüleri çözmek için kendime yönem
gerektiğini fark ve kendimi anlamak
için kendimi tanımak için önce kendime
attığım düğümleri görmek istedim Yani
öyle bir dönem geldii hayatımda köşeye
sıkışmış hissediyordum sıkıştırılmış kır
gi
Hai ma
problemler Geçit verme kıık engeller
olmadığı
görmüştüm bğ
amaçl şu için
bakslar sonki birak dah
şs
hlar
şeyden bahsetmek istiyorum Nasıl bir
seri olduğunu karşımıza çıkan her karede
fotoğra var yan yana sol taraft
i
gü
gösteri
savk şek normal Old
gösteriyor
somt yolu daha Ç çektiğim
Faki kendi içe bir akış içind devam
edece Sağdaki fot kendi içinde başka bir
akış birbirini tamamlayarak ama sağ ve
sol birbirini tamamlam devam ederek ve
projem asında daha uzun seç
kısalım bu
ilada
so
burada bir
fotoğrafta Ruhumun sesini duyana kadar
sessiz kalmayı seçtiğimi anlatmak
istiyorum kendimi tanımadan önce
gözlemem gerekiyordu şimdiye kadar
herkesi her şeyi dış faktörleri
gözlemleyen Yağmur ilk defa kendi içine
dönmeye başlamıştı ve Aslında şehrin ya
da tüm O büyük binaların göründüğünden
ne kadar küçük olduğunu ve için ne kar
büyük olduğu
gördüm
As benim iç dünyamda olan çatışmalar
sonucuydu on nl görürsem öyleydi çok
büyük şeyler GK küçülüyordu
sonra çocuksu bir merakla geçmişime
almak gereğine Karar verdim çünkü
geçmişe her baktığımda kendini tekrar
eden görmeye başım
bir buen bir
şekilde etmeye devam ediyordu bunun da
aslında düğüm olduğunu gördüm düğümü
çözdüğüm şu an takıldığım ve ilerlemeye
devam edemediğim yoldan devam
edebileceğimi düşündüm ama düğümleri
bulmak bu kadar kolay
değildi böyle sanki sonsuz bir sarmadın
içindeymişim gibi ya da böyle dikenli
çalıların arasında bir labirentte asla
çıkış yolu bulmadan aynı noktada düp
duruyormuş musun gibi bir
his
sonrasında biraz pişmanlık düğümü
görmeye başladıkça ben nasl bu düğümü
daha ön açmadım ya da nl bu düğümü
açabilirim umutsuzluk
bir ger
zor Burada
kendim
gü burc açığ karşısında Y yer Karl içind
Par küçü
aydınlığı Etkin kar büyük olduğ
düğümleri
açığımız kendiz ilka
şey bir kişi bireyin ne
kadar kendini gerçekleştirebileceği dair
umutlu olu daha kendini
gerçekleştirmemiş de
olsa Kazancı ancak deseni bozarak elde
edebilecek tahminimden büyük olduğumu
bir kere daha gördüm ve aydınlık içinde
hareket etme Fikri
doğdu sonrası iyilik
güzellik
yeni yollar yeni maceralara yol açıyordu
Çünkü düğme açtığında daha önce
girmediğin yol görüyordun ve her yol bir
öncekinden daha farklı manzaralara sahip
ve senin için bir ilk çünkü daha önce
onun bir adım ötesine
geçmişsin en büyük Yani şöyle bir söz
vardır kişinin en büyük düşmanı
dizginlenmiş düşünceleridir bu
düşünceler Pozitif ya da negatif de olsa
senin
somut gerçekliğe bakmanı engelliyorsa ve
olanı olduğundan farklı algılamam sebep
oluyorsa her zaman bir düğüm atar Bu
düğümü kend ATM da bazen sosyal
çevredeki insanların ailenin okul
arkadaşlarının toplumun otobüsteki
teyzenin falan s küçükler
görebilirsin ben varım kendi görüntümü
bir busu Peki kendimi gördüğümde
kazanmış oluyor muyum kazanmak Ne
sorusunu düşünmek gerekiyor
burada kazanmak Aslında kazanmayı
istediğin şey sürekli değiştiği için
kazandıkça yeni görüşler ve yeni ufuklar
aldığın için kendi içinde evrilen bir
şey ve bu evrimin sonunda sonu yok Onun
için kazanmak diye bir şey yok ama bu
kazandın mı sorusuna verilebilecek en
güzel cevap kazanmaya çok yakınım
olabilir
ben tamamen çok kişisel bir
zaten fotoğraflarla anlattığım için dş
dünyamı anlatmış oldum ama bu düğümleri
baktığımda Herkesin hayatında
görebileceğini ve kendi savaşının farklı
düğümlerini fark edebileceğini
düşünüyordum fotoğrafları dediğim gibi
anlatmak Aslında çok hoşuma gitmiyor
onun için bir kere de anlatmadan geçmek
istiyorum size zaman
vererek
b
kısa bir konuşma oldu Aslında anlatmak
istediğim daha fazla şeyler V olduğa
insan
heyecanlanıyor sadece kendi iç
dünyamızdaki düğümlerin sadece Bize Has
olmadığını ve karşımızdaki her kişiye
baktığımda asında kendi yansımamı
gördüğümüzü ve onun asçb fikre fikrimiz
bile olmadığı iç savaşında ona köstek
olmak yerine Onun da dışarıdan her ne
kadar her gün aynı görünse de içinde
değiştiğini bilerek düğümler imizi
çözmek istiyorum Teşekkür
ederim